This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.|||这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.|||经历一些艰难困苦，你将浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 TWO。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个惯犯骗手交往时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcast. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcast. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.|||我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back At It》播客中。1979 年对那时的我来说是个大日子。84 年对我也意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格lish。
Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the iHeart Radio,
Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the iHeart Radio,|||每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊 80 年代。84 年是个疯狂的年份。我是说，那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeartRadio 上收听 Look Back At It，
app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s.
app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s.|||App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着铠甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你们身处世界的哪个角落。非常高兴大家能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们要剖析的是二十多岁的心理学。
So I don't know about you, but it often feels like my 20s, they aren't just about like, like, like, 20s, they aren't just about, like, like growing and experiencing life. There's almost this implicit feeling that they're actually about ticking off a checklist. You know, some people call it like the 30 before 30, right? Moving out of home, graduating university, tick, get a good job, tick, find a life partner, solidify like your lifetime friendship group, buy a house, travel, invest, etc, etc. There is this very almost omnipresent blueprint given to us by, society, by our peers, by our parents, by the media about how this decade is meant to look.
So I don't know about you, but it often feels like my 20s, they aren't just about like, like, like, 20s, they aren't just about, like, like growing and experiencing life. There's almost this implicit feeling that they're actually about ticking off a checklist. You know, some people call it like the 30 before 30, right? Moving out of home, graduating university, tick, get a good job, tick, find a life partner, solidify like your lifetime friendship group, buy a house, travel, invest, etc, etc. There is this very almost omnipresent blueprint given to us by, society, by our peers, by our parents, by the media about how this decade is meant to look.|||所以我不确定你们的情况怎样，但我常常觉得我的二十多岁，不仅仅是关于，那种，二十多岁，不只是关于成长和体验生活。几乎有一种潜移默化的感觉，它们实际上是关于勾选清单上的项目。你知道，有些人称之为 30 岁前的 30 件事，对吧？搬出家门，大学毕业，打勾，找个好工作，打勾，找个伴侣，巩固你一生的朋友圈，买房，旅行，投资，等等，等等。社会、同龄人、父母、媒体几乎无处不在地给我们提供了一份蓝图，关于这个十年应该是什么样子。
And it's quite linear and consecutive. It's constantly moving forwards and upwards. But what if you are one of those people? One of many of us who find themselves completely starting over in their 20s, starting from scratch. The carefully laid plans, you know, kind of may have crumbled the future that we'd imagined. Anne had been so sure of suddenly doesn't seem that fun and enjoyable anymore. Maybe we've realized that we've made a mistake.
And it's quite linear and consecutive. It's constantly moving forwards and upwards. But what if you are one of those people? One of many of us who find themselves completely starting over in their 20s, starting from scratch. The carefully laid plans, you know, kind of may have crumbled the future that we'd imagined. Anne had been so sure of suddenly doesn't seem that fun and enjoyable anymore. Maybe we've realized that we've made a mistake.|||而且它是相当线性的、连续的。它一直在向前、向上发展。但是如果你是那种人呢？在我们当中有许多人发现自己在二十多岁时完全重新开始，从头再来。精心制定的计划，你知道，可能会土崩瓦解，我们曾想象过的未来。安曾如此确信的事情突然间似乎不再那么有趣和享受了。也许我们意识到自己犯了错误。
We need to leave the relationship, leave the job, leave the city we're in, leave the friendship, leave the life that we've kind of created so far. That is a reality for a lot of us. It is very hard to admit to ourselves when and that we do need to start over. So hard, in fact, I think, that few of us ever really do. Instead, we endure a life and we endure a reality that doesn't fit us because the prospect of the unknown and of starting over feels not only shameful but very scary. However, when we do admit it to ourselves that we are ready to start over or when that decision is kind of thrust on us, I think it can be quite liberating if we take a different perspective on it. Now I don't want to discount that there is going to be fear there.
We need to leave the relationship, leave the job, leave the city we're in, leave the friendship, leave the life that we've kind of created so far. That is a reality for a lot of us. It is very hard to admit to ourselves when and that we do need to start over. So hard, in fact, I think, that few of us ever really do. Instead, we endure a life and we endure a reality that doesn't fit us because the prospect of the unknown and of starting over feels not only shameful but very scary. However, when we do admit it to ourselves that we are ready to start over or when that decision is kind of thrust on us, I think it can be quite liberating if we take a different perspective on it. Now I don't want to discount that there is going to be fear there.|||我们需要离开这段感情，离开这份工作，离开我们所在的城市，离开这段友谊，离开我们迄今为止创造的生活。这对我们很多人来说是一个现实。当我们需要重新开始时，对自己承认这一点是非常困难的。事实上，我认为这太难了，以至于很少有人真正做到。相反，我们忍受着一种不适合我们的生活和现实，因为面对未知的未来和重新开始的前景，不仅让人感到羞耻，而且非常可怕。然而，当我们向自己承认我们准备好重新开始时，或者当这个决定被强加给我们时，如果我们换个角度来看待它，我认为这会是一种相当解脱的体验。现在我并不想低估其中会伴随的恐惧。
There is going to be confusion, especially since we feel like we've fallen off the blueprint. We maybe don't have plans anymore. We don't have seemingly in our mind an ideal sense of the future. But I really want to talk about why that is okay and why this is actually a very common experience. and if you're feeling isolated, overwhelmed, maybe shameful as we, you know, ashamed as we mentioned before, that is exactly what I would expect you to be feeling in this moment. But it shouldn't discourage you or shouldn't make you feel like you haven't made the right choice or that this is actually going to turn out completely entirely okay.
There is going to be confusion, especially since we feel like we've fallen off the blueprint. We maybe don't have plans anymore. We don't have seemingly in our mind an ideal sense of the future. But I really want to talk about why that is okay and why this is actually a very common experience. and if you're feeling isolated, overwhelmed, maybe shameful as we, you know, ashamed as we mentioned before, that is exactly what I would expect you to be feeling in this moment. But it shouldn't discourage you or shouldn't make you feel like you haven't made the right choice or that this is actually going to turn out completely entirely okay.|||会有困惑，尤其是当我们觉得自己偏离了蓝图的时候。我们可能不再有计划了。我们的脑海中似乎没有了对未来的理想感觉。但我真的很想谈谈为什么这没关系，为什么这其实是一种非常普遍的经历。如果你感到孤立、不知所措，或者像我们之前提到的那样感到羞耻，你知道的，感到羞愧，这正是我预料到你此刻会有的感受。但这不应该让你气馁，也不应该让你觉得你没有做出正确的选择，或者这最终会完全变好。
We are going to discuss some of the common ways that we are forced to start over in our 20, the biggest reasons why we have so much fear towards this experience, whether that's because of timeline comparison or the fear of the unknown, lots of identity, our attachment to comfort, we're going to discuss all of those factors. Plus, and this is the most important part of this episode, how to shift from that really fear-based mindset to an opportunity-based mindset when you encounter the opportunity to start over in your 20s. I also really want to share some listener stories.
We are going to discuss some of the common ways that we are forced to start over in our 20, the biggest reasons why we have so much fear towards this experience, whether that's because of timeline comparison or the fear of the unknown, lots of identity, our attachment to comfort, we're going to discuss all of those factors. Plus, and this is the most important part of this episode, how to shift from that really fear-based mindset to an opportunity-based mindset when you encounter the opportunity to start over in our 20s. I also really want to share some listener stories.|||我们将讨论在二十多岁时被迫重新开始的一些常见方式，我们对这种经历产生如此多恐惧的最大原因，无论是由于时间线比较还是对未知的恐惧，身份的丧失，我们对舒适区的依恋，我们将讨论所有这些因素。此外，这也是本期节目最重要的一部分，当你遇到在二十多岁重新开始的机会时，如何从那种完全基于恐惧的心态转变为基于机会的心态。我也非常想分享一些听众的故事。
I've been doing that more and more because I just feel like there is so much wisdom from the community. And sometimes I think just hearing that other people are going through what you are going through is the assurance that we all need. And I want to remind you, just because something about your life isn't working out right now doesn't mean that the rest of your life is doomed. That is the main philosophy and theme that we will be promoting in this episode. So I hope that if you are in this position, this brings you comfort, knowledge, information, maybe just a sense of calm. And without further ado, let's get into the episode. What does it feel like to start over in your 20s?
I've been doing that more and more because I just feel like there is so much wisdom from the community. And sometimes I think just hearing that other people are going through what you are going through is the assurance that we all need. And I want to remind you, just because something about your life isn't working out right now doesn't mean that the rest of your life is doomed. That is the main philosophy and theme that we will be promoting in this episode. So I hope that if you are in this position, this brings you comfort, knowledge, information, maybe just a sense of calm. And without further ado, let's get into the episode. What does it feel like to start over in your 20s?|||我越来越频繁地这样做，因为我只是觉得社区里蕴含着如此多的智慧。有时我认为，仅仅听到别人也在经历你所经历的事情，就是我们所有人需要的保证。我想提醒你，仅仅因为你生活的某一部分现在进展不顺，并不意味着你的余生就注定失败。这就是我们将在本期节目中推广的主要哲学和主题。所以我希望如果你正处于这种处境，这能带给你安慰、知识、信息，或者仅仅是一丝平静。闲话少说，让我们进入正题。在二十多岁时重新开始是什么感觉？
I want to share a story from a listener, actually, to start us off. And I think this story just really captures the, I don't know, the essence of what it feels like to start over. Hey Gemma, I want to share my story of starting over in hopes that it will help someone else feel less like a failure because they didn't get it right the first time. When I was 27, I had my dream job. I was making commercials, working my way up to potentially being a film director. I had all of these friends, a nice flat. I was living in London with my boyfriend who I'd met at 22. We lived together and we had a cat and I thought for sure he was going to propose in the next year.
I want to share a story from a listener, actually, to start us off. And I think this story just really captures the, I don't know, the essence of what it feels like to start over. Hey Gemma, I want to share my story of starting over in hopes that it will help someone else feel less like a failure because they didn't get it right the first time. When I was 27, I had my dream job. I was making commercials, working my way up to potentially being a film director. I had all of these friends, a nice flat. I was living in London with my boyfriend who I'd met at 22. We lived together and we had a cat and I thought for sure he was going to propose in the next year.|||事实上，我想先分享一位听众的故事来开启我们的节目。我认为这个故事真正捕捉到了，我不知道，重新开始的感觉的精髓。嘿，杰玛，我想分享我重新开始的故事，希望它能帮助其他人因为第一次没有做好而少感到自己是个失败者。在我 27 岁的时候，我拥有了我的梦想工作。我当时在拍广告，一步步努力朝着可能成为电影导演的目标前进。我有很多朋友，有一套不错的公寓。我和我 22 岁时认识的男朋友一起住在伦敦。我们住在一起，养了一只猫，我笃定他会在接下来的一年里向我求婚。
everything basically just seemed laid out perfectly in front of me. Within the span of two months, I lost my job when COVID started. My boyfriend broke up with me because he caught feelings for one of his co-workers, and my dad had a stroke, so I moved back home to take care of him. Enter my dark days. For the next year, it felt like my trajectory was permanently changed, and I was going to be a failure and miserable. This was the beginning of the end.
everything basically just seemed laid out perfectly in front of me. Within the span of two months, I lost my job when COVID started. My boyfriend broke up with me because he caught feelings for one of his co-workers, and my dad had a stroke, so I moved back home to take care of him. Enter my dark days. For the next year, it felt like my trajectory was permanently changed, and I was going to be a failure and miserable. This was the beginning of the end.|||一切似乎都完美地摆在我的面前。在两个月内，随着新冠疫情的爆发，我失业了。我男朋友因为对他的一个同事产生了感情而和我分手了，我爸爸中风了，所以我搬回家照顾他。进入了我的黑暗日子。在接下来的一年里，感觉我的人生轨迹被永远地改变了，我将成为一个失败者并痛苦不堪。这是结束的开始。
I hadn't felt this uncertain since I was. I was 17, because in the last 10 years, the next step had always been obvious for me. And I guess I took that for granted. Slowly, but surely, I started to really think, what do I want the next 10 years of my life to look like? What is going to make me happy? I started to put things into action, and now I can confidently say that I am happier than ever.
I hadn't felt this uncertain since I was. I was 17, because in the last 10 years, the next step had always been obvious for me. And I guess I took that for graded. Slowly, but surely, I started to really think, what do I want the next 10 years of my life to look like? What is going to make me happy? I started to put things into action, and now I can confidently say that I am happier than ever.|||自从我 17 岁以来，我从未感到如此不确定，因为在过去的 10 年里，下一步该怎么走对我来说一直都是显而易见的。我想我是把这视为理所当然了。稳扎稳打地，我开始认真思考：我希望我人生接下来的 10 年是什么样子的？什么能让我快乐？我开始付诸行动，现在我可以自信地说，我比以往任何时候都快乐。
My dad got better, and now I live in Italy, and I teach yoga. I got certified two years ago. I run my own business as well. I live in my own apartment with my two cats now and have a beautiful community around me. It honestly scares me to think that this life almost didn't happen and that I thought what I had before was the peak of happiness, not even close. So this email, I got this email before I even announced that I was going to do this episode. This person must have just known that maybe someone else out there needed to hear it. and it honestly left me really emotional.
My dad got better, and now I live in Italy, and I teach yoga. I got certified two years ago. I run my own business as well. I live in my own apartment with my two cats now and have a beautiful community around me. It honestly scares me to think that this life almost didn't happen and that I thought what I had before was the peak of happiness, not even close. So this email, I got this email before I even announced that I was going to do this episode. This person must have just known that maybe someone else out there needed to hear it. and it honestly left me really emotional.|||我爸爸身体好转了，现在我住在意大利，教瑜伽。我两年前获得了认证。我也经营着自己的生意。我现在和我的两只猫住在自己的公寓里，身边有一个美好的社区。一想到这种生活差点就没有发生，而我曾经以为之前拥有的就是幸福的巅峰，甚至相差十万八千里，这着实让我感到害怕。所以这封邮件，我在宣布要做这期节目之前就收到了这封邮件。这个人一定只是知道，也许外面的某个人需要听到它。这着实让我非常感动。
And I just want to repeat my favorite part once more because it's incredible. This is the part that I love. It honestly scares me to think that this life almost didn't happen. Now, is that not the most beautiful and wise reminder from someone who has lived through and experienced this thing that we kind of fear everything falling apart? That is what happened to her and she's fine now. You know, I just couldn't not include this story because sometimes, like I said, just hearing how someone else's circumstances have turned out is enough to sue their own doubt in a way. I think this story is also incredible because it touches on three very unique ways that we may be forced to start over in our 20s.
And I just want to repeat my favorite part once more because it's incredible. This is the part that I love. It honestly scares me to think that this life almost didn't happen. Now, is that not the most beautiful and wise reminder from someone who has lived through and experienced this thing that we kind of fear everything falling apart? That is what happened to her and she's fine now. You know, I just couldn't not include this story because sometimes, like I said, just hearing how someone else's circumstances have turned out is enough to sue their own doubt in a way. I think this story is also incredible because it touches on three very unique ways that we may be forced to start over in our 20s.|||我只想再次重复我最喜欢的部分，因为这太不可思议了。这就是我最喜欢的部分。一想到这种生活差点没有发生，我真的感到害怕。现在，对于一个经历过并体验过我们都有些恐惧的一切分崩离析的人来说，这难道不是最美丽、最明智的提醒吗？这就是她所经历的，而她现在过得很好。你知道，我不能不把这个故事包含进来，因为有时，就像我说的，仅仅听到别人的情况如何好转，就足以在某种程度上平息他们自己的疑虑。我认为这个故事也很不可思议，因为它触及了我们在二十多岁时可能被迫重新开始的三种非常独特的方式。
Relationships, career and location, but also family and priorities. So actually almost five. And each of them feels so uniquely significant. It just blows my mind that this person. and experience so many different, you know, so many different ways of life becoming chaotic all at once, and she survived. So let's talk about the ways in which we might be forced to start over. And I'm going to focus on career first because I think when our career intentions and dreams change or our path becomes unclear, we can feel very unmoored, usually because our identity
Relationships, career and location, but also family and priorities. So actually almost five. And each of them feels so uniquely significant. It just blows my mind that this person. and experience so many different, you know, so many different ways of life becoming chaotic all at once, and she survived. So let's talk about the ways in which we might be forced to start over. And I'm going to focus on career first because I think when our career intentions and dreams change or our path becomes unclear, we can feel very unmoored, usually because our identity|||感情、事业和地点，还有家庭和生活重心。所以实际上将近五个。而且每一个都显得如此独特而重要。我简直不敢相信这个人经历了如此多不同的，你知道的，如此多种生活方式同时陷入混乱的情况，而她挺过来了。所以让我们来谈谈我们可能被迫重新开始的方式。我将首先关注事业，因为我认为当我们的职业意图和梦想改变，或者我们的道路变得不清晰时，我们会感到非常迷茫，通常是因为我们的身份
is somewhat, if not, seriously tied to our vocation and what we do for a living, what we're pursuing, especially in our 20s, right? It just feels like work is at the center. We are meant to be climbing the corporate ladder, working really hard, figuring out what we want to do. So when we don't feel like we know or we feel like we do know when it's not working out, it can be very distressing. There are many ways that this kind of happens to us. You may have been unexpectedly fired or made redundant in the last couple of years. You may even get to a stage where you realize that you're just faking it. You know, this isn't what you want anymore or the industry is changing and you just can't
is somewhat, if not, seriously tied to our vocation and what we do for a living, what we're pursuing, especially in our 20s, right? It just feels like work is at the center. We are meant to be climbing the corporate ladder, working really hard, figuring out what we want to do. So when we don't feel like we know or we feel like we do know when it's not working out, it can be very distressing. There are many ways that this kind of happens to us. You may have been unexpectedly fired or made redundant in the last couple of years. You may even get to a stage where you realize that you're just faking it. You know, this isn't what you want anymore or the industry is changing and you just can't|||或多或少，如果不是严重的话，与我们的职业以及我们谋生的手段、我们追求的目标息息相关，尤其是在我们二十多岁的时候，对吧？感觉工作就是核心。我们理应在职场上不断晋升，努力工作，弄清楚自己想做什么。因此，当我们觉得自已不知道，或者觉得自已知道却发现行不通时，会让人感到非常痛苦。这种情况以多种方式发生在我们身上。在过去的几年里，你可能意外地被解雇或被裁员。你甚至可能到了这样一个阶段：你意识到自己只是在假装。你知道，这已经不是你想要的了，或者行业正在发生变化，而你偏偏无法
get the job. You've pushed yourself so hard. You're not getting any traction. Sometimes we reach a tipping point in these circumstances where we realize, okay, I gave it a go. It might be time to abandon ship. I'm not happy here anymore. It's not working out.
get the job. You've pushed yourself so hard. You're not getting any traction. Sometimes we reach a tipping point in these circumstances where we realize, okay, I gave it a go. It might be time to abandon ship. I'm not happy here anymore. It's not working out.|||找到工作。你把自己逼得太紧了。你没有任何进展。有时在这些情况下，我们会到达一个临界点，我们意识到，好吧，我尝试过了。也许是时候弃船了。我在这里不再快乐了。这行不通。
and yes the future feels unclear but so does this current timeline that I'm on when you really actually consider it and sit with this reality for a lot of people you kind of realize that a lot of us are basically forced to put ourselves on a career or a professional trajectory very early on at like 17 or 18 years old and i don't know about you but 17 year old jemma she had no idea what she wanted. She thought she knew. She thought she was a genius. She thought she had it all figured out. Absolutely. No way. She was so naive. That was a big wake up call when, you know, I started to think, huh, maybe what I dreamt about at 17 or 18 isn't what 24 year old me actually cares about anymore. And if you're going through that right now, I really feel for you. But I also think it's important to actually periodically reflect on what you actually want from your professional life and make changes where you deem necessary kind of before it's too late. The second biggest dimension area where we feel
and yes the future feels unclear but so does this current timeline that I'm on when you really actually consider it and sit with this reality for a lot of years you kind of realize that a lot of us are basically forced to put ourselves on a career or a professional trajectory very early on at like 17 or 18 years old and i don't know about you but 17 year old jemma she had no idea what she wanted. She thought she knew. She thought she was a genius. She thought she had it all figured out. Absolutely. No way. She was so naive. That was a big wake up call when, you know, I started to think, huh, maybe what I dreamt about at 17 or 18 isn't what 24 year old me actually cares about anymore. And if you're going through that right now, I really feel for you. But I also think it's important to actually periodically reflect on what you actually want from your professional life and make changes where you deem necessary kind of before it's too late. The second biggest dimension area where we feel|||是的，未来感觉很不确定，但我目前的时间线也是如此。当你真正去思考并在多年后面对这个现实时，你就会意识到，我们中的很多人基本上在很早的时候，比如在 17 或 18 岁时，就被迫把自己置于一条职业轨迹上。我不知道你们怎么样，但 17 岁的杰玛根本不知道自己想要什么。她以为自己知道。她以为自己是个天才。她以为她把一切都想明白了。绝对没有。她太天真了。当我知道，当我开始思考时，这是一个巨大的警钟：嗯，也许我在 17 或 18 岁时梦想的事情已经不是 24 岁的我真正关心的了。如果你现在正在经历这些，我真的对你感同身受。但我也认为，定期反思你对职业生活真正想要什么，并在你认为必要的地方做出改变是很重要的，免得为时已晚。我们感觉到的第二个最大维度领域
like we could be starting over is our relationships. Now I mean both platonic and romantic, but let's really zoom in on romantic for a second. So I was talking to my friend Steph the other day about something that's happening in our friendship circle, which is there has been a series of long-term relationship breakups that have occurred amongst our friends. And I am talking like five, seven, 10-year relationships all coming to an end. It's like everyone turns 27, realizes they're closer to 30 than ever before, their satin returns, and they break up. So that period between around 27 to 29 is when a lot of us experience our first major breakup with a long-term partner. Maybe that's someone that you've fallen in love within your early 20s and now, you know,
like we could be starting over is our relationships. Now I mean both platonic and romantic, but let's really zoom in on romantic for a second. So I was talking to my friend Steph the other day about something that's happening in our friendship circle, which is there has been a series of long-term relationship breakups that have occurred amongst our friends. And I am talking like five, seven, 10-year relationships all coming to an end. It's like everyone turns 27, realizes they're closer to 30 than ever before, their satin returns, and they break up. So that period between around 27 to 29 is when a lot of us experience our first major breakup with a long-term partner. Maybe that's someone that you've fallen in love within your early 20s and now, you know,|||可能是重新开始的是我们的感情。现在我指的是柏拉图式的友情和浪漫的爱情，但让我们花点时间仔细聚焦于浪漫关系。前几天我和我的朋友斯蒂芬谈论我们朋友圈里发生的一件事，那就是我们的一群朋友中发生了一系列长期关系的破裂。我说的是像五、七、十年的恋情都走到了尽头。就像每个人到了 27 岁，意识到自己比以往任何时候都更接近 30 岁，他们的土星回归了，然后他们就分手了。所以在 27 到 29 岁之间的这段时期，我们很多人会经历与长期伴侣的第一次重大分手。也许那是你在二十出头时坠入爱河的人，现在，你知道的，
you are faced with the idea of entering 30 with them. You realize that you want to enter it with someone else. But it's very common for people to reach their late 20s and see a real flip in their relationship priorities. And it's not a coincidence. It's been suggested by some social. psychologist that 27 to 30, 27 to 29 is a very serious and key stage in relationships where you're kind of at this age where you either get serious or you get out. I think that's how a lot of us feel.
you are faced with the idea of entering 30 with them. You realize that you want to enter it with someone else. But it's very common for people to reach their late 20s and see a real flip in their relationship priorities. And it's not a coincidence. It's been suggested by some social. psychologist that 27 to 30, 27 to 29 is a very serious and key stage in relationships where you're kind of at this age where you either get serious or you get out. I think that's how a lot of us feel.|||你面临着和他们一起迈入 30 岁的想法。你意识到你想和另一个人一起跨入这个门槛。但人们到了二十多岁快结束时，感情重心发生真正的翻转是非常普遍的。这并非巧合。一些社会心理学家指出，27 到 30 岁，27 到 29 岁是恋爱关系中一个非常严肃和关键的阶段，在这个年龄，你要么认真对待，要么就离开。我想我们很多人都是这种感觉。
This is also known by another name. It's called the seven year itch. I don't know if you've heard that name before, but it basically refers to this idea that at around seven years a relationship either needs to change or needs to be left behind. And either you evolve together or you go your separate ways. This is actually one of the main timeline hurdles for a relationship. It's typically six months, two years and seven years. Those are the times in which people are most likely to break up. It follows a very similar pattern for a lot of us.
This is also known by another name. It's called the seven year itch. I don't know if you've heard that name before, but it basically refers to this idea that at around seven years a relationship either needs to change or needs to be left behind. And either you evolve together or you go your separate ways. This is actually one of the main timeline hurdles for a relationship. It's typically six months, two years and seven years. Those are the times in which people are most likely to break up. It follows a very similar pattern for a lot of us.|||这也叫另一个名字。它被称为“七年之痒”。我不知道你以前是否听过这个名字，但它基本上是指这样一种观点：在大约七年的时间里，一段关系要么需要改变，要么需要被抛在脑后。要么你们一起进化，要么你们分道扬镳。这实际上是感情关系中主要的时间线障碍之一。通常是六个月、两年和七年。这些是人们最有可能分手的时间。对于我们许多人来说，它遵循着非常相似的模式。
Even as I'm telling you this though, you might be comforted by the science. You might be able to say, oh, okay, so, This is normal. I don't think that reduces the fact that it's a very serious, deep, profoundly moving loss. No one enters a relationship thinking this has an expiry date and at 27 I'll break up and find someone new. Typically we are in it for the long haul. We're committed to this person. So I also think that even if you know deep down, this is what is right.
Even as I'm telling you this though, you might be comforted by the science. You might be able to say, oh, okay, so, This is normal. I don't think that reduces the fact that it's a very serious, deep, profoundly moving loss. No one enters a relationship thinking this has an expiry date and at 27 I'll break up and find someone new. Typically we are in it for the long haul. We're committed to this person. So I also think that even if you know deep down, this is what is right.|||然而，即使我在告诉你这些，你可能会被科学所安慰。你可能会说：“哦，好吧，所以，这是正常的。”我认为这并不能减少这样一个事实：这是一场非常严重、深刻、触及灵魂的失落。没有人进入一段感情会认为这有保质期，到了 27 岁我就会分手并找个新对象。通常我们都是为了长远打算。我们对这个人做出了承诺。所以我也认为，即使你内心深处知道，这是正确的事情。
You will find someone else or you will be okay alone. it doesn't lessen the sting, at least in the first three to six months. It's definitely, I think, not made any easier by this societal stigma around being single and the sense that if you're not partnered up, you are not whole. You're either in a couple or you're half a person. You must be either looking for love or in love. You know, how could you possibly be in that middle space of just being happy by yourself? another way that we typically start over in our 20s is financially.
You will find someone else or you will be okay alone. it doesn't lessen the sting, at least in the first three to six months. It's definitely, I think, not made any easier by this societal stigma around being single and the sense that if you're not partnered up, you are not whole. You're either in a couple or you're half a person. You must be either looking for love or in love. You know, how could you possibly be in that middle space of just being happy by yourself? another way that we typically start over in our 20s is financially.|||你会找到别人，或者你独自一人也能过得很好。它不会减轻痛苦，至少在前三到六个月里是这样。我认为，社会对单身的污名化，以及如果你没有伴侣就不完整的这种感觉，绝对没有让这一切变得更容易。你要么处于一段伴侣关系中，要么你就是半个人。你一定要么在寻找爱情，要么正在恋爱中。你知道，你怎么可能处于那种独自一我们在二十多岁时通常重新开始的另一种方式是在经济上。
Maybe you've made a big purchase, maybe you've lost money, maybe you've gone all in on traveling, you've come back with nothing. I see this a lot. I actually don't think it's a bad thing. I think that what is money if it's not something that unlocks a better life for you? And for some people, money unlocks the security and comfort of a home or of long-term financial stability. for others it unlocks things like travel and it unlocks things like giving yourself the experiences
Maybe you've made a big purchase, maybe you've lost money, maybe you've gone all in on traveling, you've come back with nothing. I see this a lot. I actually don't think it's a bad thing. I think that what is money if it's not something that unlocks a better life for you? And for some people, money unlocks the security and comfort of a home or of long-term financial stability. for others it unlocks things like travel and it unlocks things like giving yourself the experiences|||也许你有一笔大额消费，也许你亏了钱，也许你孤注一掷去旅行，结果一无所有地回来。我经常看到这种情况。我其实认为这不是一件坏事。我认为，如果钱不是用来为你开启更好生活的工具，那它算什么呢？对某些人来说，钱开启了家的安全感和舒适感，或者是长期的财务稳定。对另一些人来说，它开启了诸如旅行之类的事情，它开启了给予自己
you maybe always wanted as a child or giving yourself kind of that texture to life so financially i think obviously i'm not going to give you financial advice and you do what is best for you and what feels most aligned with your life priorities but i think starting over financially in our 20s is not always this big dark looming cloud that is promising you failure for for the rest of your years right i don't think that it's a mistake to spend your money even if it means not having as much as people your own age or feeling like you don't have as much saved as you know tom down the road or beth up the street also um kind of on a similar note not really but moving this is a time our 20s are a time when a lot of us want to live in and see new places.
you maybe always wanted as a child or giving yourself kind of that texture to life so financially i think obviously i'm not going to give you financial advice and you do what is best for you and what feels most aligned with your life priorities but i think starting over financially in our 20s is not always this big dark looming cloud that is promising you failure for for the rest of your years right i don't think that it's a mistake to spend your money even if it means not having as much as people your own age or feeling like you don't have as much saved as you know tom down the road or beth up the street also um kind of on a similar note not really but moving this is a time our 20s are a time when a lot of us want to live in and see new places.|||你可能从小就一直想要的体验，或者给你的生活增添那种质感。所以在经济上，我想显然我不会给你理财建议，你要做对你最好、最符合你生活重心的事情。但我认为在二十多岁时在经济上重新开始并不总是一片巨大的阴云，它预示着你余生都会失败，对吧？我不认为花钱是个错误，即使这意味着你拥有的不如同龄人多，或者觉得自已没有像你知道的街那头的汤姆或街那边的贝丝那样存下那么多钱。另外，嗯，有点类似但又不太一样，搬家，这是一个时期，我们的二十多岁是一个让我们很多人想要去居住和看新地方的时期。
The amount of friends that I have who have moved to London in the last year, shocking. Shocking. I have this joke that like every Australian turns 25 and moves to London and every person in the UK turns 25 and moves to Australia. Like it honestly feels that way. But really, it is a time when we're looking for a refresh. We're looking for a new environment. We're looking for new friends.
The amount of friends that I have who have moved to London in the last year, shocking. Shocking. I have this joke that like every Australian turns 25 and moves to London and every person in the UK turns 25 and moves to Australia. Like it honestly feels that way. But really, it is a time when we're looking for a refresh. We're looking for a new environment. We're looking for new friends.|||在过去的一年里，我搬到伦敦的朋友数量惊人。太惊人了。我有个笑话，说每个澳大利亚人一到 25 岁就搬到伦敦，而每个英国人一到 25 岁就搬到澳大利亚。感觉真的就是这样。但实际上，这是一个我们在寻找焕然一新的时机。我们在寻找一个新的环境。我们在寻找新的朋友。
Adjusting to that, though, isn't always going to be a fairy tale. We like comfort. We like what we know. And there will be probably a period of disconnect where you don't have the same community or knowledge of a city or a space that you did when you lived back at home. I have a rule for situations like this though. If you are lucky enough to move to a new city or a new country, I need you to give it at least six months, six months where you cannot decide whether to stay or to go. because that period of time is typically how long it does take to learn a new place, to solidify some new friendships, to feel comfortable in a new job,
Adjusting to that, though, isn't always going to be a fairy tale. We like comfort. We like what we know. And there will be probably a period of disconnect where you don't have the same community or knowledge of a city or a space that you did when you lived back at home. I have a rule for situations like this though. If you are lucky enough to move to a new city or a new country, I need you to give it at least six months, six months where you cannot decide whether to stay or to go. because that period of time is typically how long it does take to learn a new place, to solidify some new friendships, to feel comfortable in a new job,|||然而，适应这一切并不总是一帆风顺的。我们喜欢舒适。我们喜欢我们熟悉的事物。可能还会有一段脱节期，在这个时期，你没有像住在家里时那样对一个城市或空间的社区认同感或了解。不过，对于这种情况，我有一个规则。如果你有幸搬到一个新的城市或国家，我需要你给它至少六个月的时间，在这六个月里，你不能决定是去还是留。因为这段时间通常是一座新地方真正需要的时间：去了解一个新地方，巩固一些新的友谊，在新的工作岗位上感到舒适，
and to get a sense of home. So if part of your fresh start in your 20s has been a significant move and you're struggling, you're thinking, oh my God, like fuck, I made it terrible decision. Please keep the six-month rule in mind. one final way that we typically see people restarting during this decade is almost like a complete overhaul. It's not to do with finances. It's not to do with relationships, career, it's everything. It is a refresh and a rebirth or most of our entire personality where we decide we need new hobbies, we need new beliefs, we need new clothes, new habits. It's part of our personal evolution.
and to get a sense of home. So if part of your fresh start in your 20s has been a significant move and you're struggling, you're thinking, oh my God, like fuck, I made it terrible decision. Please keep the six-month rule in mind. one final way that we typically see people restarting during this decade is almost like a complete overhaul. It's not to do with finances. It's not to do with relationships, career, it's everything. It is a refresh and a rebirth or most of our entire personality where we decide we need new hobbies, we need new beliefs, we need new clothes, new habits. It's part of our personal evolution.|||并获得一种家的感觉。所以，如果你在二十多岁时的全新开始包括了一次重大的搬迁，而你正在苦苦挣扎，你心想：“天哪，真他妈的，我做出 了一个糟糕的决定。”请记住六个月的规则。我们通常看到人们在这十年中重新开始的最后一种方式，几乎就像是一次彻底的重塑。这与财务无关。这与人际关系、事业无关，这是全部。这是对我们大部分整个个性的刷新和重生，我们决定我们需要新的爱好，我们需要新的信仰，我们需要新的衣服，新的习惯。这是我们个人演变的一部分。
And I think normally when we get to that point where we do feel like we need to transform ourselves as people, we've definitely reached an internal or emotional tipping point where at some stage you realize that you are no longer happy and you will never be happy in this current version of yourself. So that is definitely another way that we are promised a fresh start in our 20s. So these are the most common core examples. I'll also say that at the time of recording this, you know, there are huge fires in LA and many people have had to start over because of something completely. completely drastic, dramatic, out of their control like a natural disaster. And those experiences for other people sometimes really put into perspective our own problems. But it really does go to show that you can do everything right and there can still be factors
And I think normally when we get to that point where we do feel like we need to transform ourselves as people, we've definitely reached an internal or emotional tipping point where at some stage you realize that you are no longer happy and you will never be happy in this current version of yourself. So that is definitely another way that we are promised a fresh start in our 20s. So these are the most common core examples. I'll also say that at the time of recording this, you know, there are huge fires in LA and many people have had to start over because of something completely. completely drastic, dramatic, out of their control like a natural disaster. And those experiences for other people sometimes really put into perspective our own problems. But it really does go to show that you can do everything right and there can still be factors|||我想通常当我们到达那个我们确实觉得需要改变自已作为人的地步时，我们绝对已经达到了一个内部或情感上的临界点，在某个阶段你意识到你不再快乐，并且在你目前的这个版本中你将永远不会快乐。所以这绝对是我们被承诺在二十多岁时获得全新开始的另一种方式。这些是最常见核心例子。我还要说的是，在录制这段音频时，你知道，洛杉矶发生了大火，许多人不得不因为一些完全彻底、剧烈、戏剧性且超出他们控制的事情（比如自然灾害）而重新开始。对其他人来说，这些经历有时真的能让我们正确看待我们自己的问题。但这确实表明，你可以把所有事情都做好，却依然会有各种因素
outside of your control that can get to you and that can force a fresh start. So when we are either involuntarily or voluntarily push to restart and start over in our 20s, we are likely to encounter some pretty emotional, psychological, hard barriers or things that make it difficult and that bring about doubt and confusion. And I want to talk about all of those after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental tough. fitness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical
outside of your control that can get to you and that can force a fresh start. So when we are either involuntarily or voluntarily push to restart and start over in our 20s, we are likely to encounter some pretty emotional, psychological, hard barriers or things that make it difficult and that bring about doubt and confusion. And I want to talk about all of those after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental tough. fitness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical|||超出你的控制范围，这些因素会影响到你，并迫使你重新开始。因此，当我们非自愿或自愿被推动在二十多岁时重新开始时，我们很可能会遇到一些相当情绪化、心理上的艰难障碍，或者让事情变得困难并带来怀疑和困惑的事情。在短暂的休息之后，我想谈谈所有这些。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家等对话，抛开那些不切实际的
and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.|||和过于复杂的、主导养生行业的伪科学。我们真的曾认为植物油天生就有炎症性。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更 healthier 的人。收听《2%》。即在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 TWO percent。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jette. Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jette. Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.|||我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和金小妹到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。亚历克斯·英格lish。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期节目与马克·拉蒙特·希尔一起畅谈 80 年代的快克。需要说明的是，84 年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊快克，但只是想让你们知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.|||我是说，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以我开始看到其中有一条主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病，所以。谢谢你帮我把话说完。我认为没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back At It。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.|||欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们的主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that- and that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.|||生活变成了一场关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两个不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。而且这——这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones.
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones.|||加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，我们将就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和人生目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索“Learn the Hardway”并立即收听。在 2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己身处一场父权丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露出她证词中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战以证明真相。你在宣誓后两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.|||这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税钱被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Admitting to yourself and I guess to others that you have had to start over. in your 20s in some capacity, it can bring about a lot of shame and fear.
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Admitting to yourself and I guess to others that you have had to start over. in your 20s in some capacity, it can bring about a lot of shame and fear.|||这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没有结束。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。向自己承认，我猜也向其他人承认，你不得不在二十多岁时在某种程度上重新开始。这会带来很多羞耻和恐惧。
And we associate it with feeling like we've failed or feeling like we're disappointing people or like you've wasted those early years. Why does it feel so weird to admit to ourselves and to others that we're starting over? I think the first reason that this is so hard, and I would say the primary reason in this generation is timeline comparison. As humans, part of our DNA, I guess, part of our blueprint, our social blueprint has evolved to compare, to look at our peers or our friends as a way to see whether we are doing this whole life thing correctly. And if the majority of people are where we are, we largely assume we're doing okay if they're at a similar point in, you know, their life as us.
And we associate it with feeling like we've failed or feeling like we're disappointing people or like you've wasted those early years. Why does it feel so weird to admit to ourselves and to others that we're starting over? I think the first reason that this is so hard, and I would say the primary reason in this generation is timeline comparison. As humans, part of our DNA, I guess, part of our blueprint, our social blueprint has evolved to compare, to look at our peers or our friends as a way to see whether we are doing this whole life thing correctly. And if the majority of people are where we are, we largely assume we're doing okay if they're at a similar point in, you know, their life as us.|||我们将它与觉得自己失败了的感觉，或者觉得自己让别人失望了的感觉，或者觉得你浪费了那些早年时光联系在一起。为什么向自己和他人承认我们在重新开始会感觉如此奇怪？我认为这之所以如此困难的第一个原因，我可以说也是这一代人的首要原因，就是时间线比较。作为人类，我们 DNA 的一部分，我想，我们的蓝图的一部分，我们的社会蓝图已经进化到懂得比较，将我们的同龄人或朋友作为一种方式，来看看我们是否在正确地过着整个人生。如果大多数人在我们所处的位置，如果他们在人生中某个与我们相似的节点上，我们很大程度上会认为我们过得还不错。
kind of think, okay, no problems, we're fine, we're not going to fall behind, no disaster, but if our perception of other people's progress and success is that they are much more advanced than us, and that is the norm. We are engaging in something called upward social comparison, and that can really bring about a sense of pressure or shame, doubt, confusion that we are falling behind. Milestone or life trajectory is probably one of the main things that we compare ourselves on in our 20s, most likely because there is no guidebook for how well we should be going. There is no unique special way that we should be doing things. So we tend to use examples in our environment like our friends, our similarly aged colleagues, people we see online as a way to tell us. We don't
kind of think, okay, no problems, we're fine, we're not going to fall behind, no disaster, but if our perception of other people's progress and success is that they are much more advanced than us, and that is the norm. We are engaging in something called upward social comparison, and that can really bring about a sense of pressure or shame, doubt, confusion that we are falling behind. Milestone or life trajectory is probably one of the main things that we compare ourselves on in our 20s, most likely because there is no guidebook for how well we should be going. There is no unique special way that we should be doing things. So we tend to use examples in our environment like our friends, our similarly aged colleagues, people we see online as a way to tell us. We don't|||就会觉得，好吧，没问题，我们很好，我们不会落后，没有灾难，但如果我们对其他人进步和成功的看法是他们比我们先进得多，而且这才是常态。我们正在进行一种叫做向上社会比较的行为，这真的会带来一种压力感或羞耻感、怀疑感、觉得自己正在落后的困惑感。里程碑或人生轨迹可能是我们在二十多岁时与他人进行比较的主要事项之一，这很可能是因为对于我们应该过得有多好并没有一本指南。我们没有哪种独特而特殊的方式必须去遵循。所以我们倾向于使用我们环境中的例子，比如我们的朋友、年龄相仿的同事、我们在网上看到的人，作为一种告诉我们答案的方式。我们没有
realize though when we do that either consciously or unconsciously we don't realize that we have a real blind spot we do not have an accurate sample we are not seeing the whole picture we are not seeing the areas of these people's lives where they themselves feel behind in fact recent research would tell you that when we compare we are actually most likely to choose the most accomplished person we know and treat them as the average when really they're not. It's a cognitive bias that we have. The truth is there is no one correct path, but we also tend to forget that because social comparison is not rational, it's emotional, it is going to make you feel more insecure as a way to motivate you in this very human way to be like everyone else. Compounding this, I think, is this cultural
realize though when we do that either consciously or unconsciously we don't realize that we have a real blind spot we do not have an accurate sample we are not seeing the whole picture we are not seeing the areas of these people's lives where they themselves feel behind in fact recent research would tell you that when we compare we are actually most likely to choose the most accomplished person we know and treat them as the average when really they're not. It's a cognitive bias that we have. The truth is there is no one correct path, but we also tend to forget that because social comparison is not rational, it's emotional, it is going to make you feel more insecure as a way to motivate you in this very human way to be like everyone else. Compounding this, I think, is this cultural|||意识到，当我们有意识或无意识地这样做时，我们没有意识到我们有一个真正的盲点，我们没有一个准确的样本，我们没有看到全貌，我们没有看到这些人生活中他们自己也觉得落后的领域。事实上，最近的研究会告诉你，当我们进行比较时，我们实际上最有可能选择我们认识的成就最高的人，并将他们视为平均水平，而实际上他们并不是。这是我们所拥有的一种认知偏差。事实是，没有一条唯一的正确道路，但我们也往往会忘记这一点，因为社会比较不是理性的，它是情绪化的，它会让你感到更加没有安全感，以此作为一种非常人性化的方式来激励你变得和别人一样。我认为，加剧这种情况的是这种文化
narrative that we all encounter that our 20s are a make or break time, one where we are supposed to have it all figured out or at least be on our way. And this pressure really feeds into imposter syndrome, making us feel like we are constantly falling short that we don't deserve to be where we are or that even when we are someone that we're happy to be, we could be further along. The thing is, is that this kind of timeline comparison, and I'm certainly, not blaming you for indulging in it, I definitely do it as well. Sometimes it's just instinctual, but it's actually not making it any easier for us to change our lives or to move in the direction that we want. So there was a 22 study from the University of Florida that found that the more
narrative that we all encounter that our 20s are a make or break time, one where we are supposed to have it all figured out or at least be on our way. And this pressure really feeds into imposter syndrome, making us feel like we are constantly falling short that we don't deserve to be where we are or that even when we are someone that we're happy to be, we could be further along. The thing is, is that this kind of timeline comparison, and I'm certainly, not blaming you for indulging in it, I definitely do it as well. Sometimes it's just instinctual, but it's actually not making it any easier for us to change our lives or to move in the direction that we want. So there was a 22 study from the University of Florida that found that the more|||叙事：我们所有人都遇到过，我们的二十多岁是决定成败的时期，在这个时期，我们本该把一切都弄清楚，或者至少在通往成功的路上。这种压力确实助长了冒名顶替综合征，让我们觉得自己总是力不从心，不配拥有现在的处境，或者即使当我们成为一个我们乐于成为的人时，我们本可以走得更远。问题是，这种时间线比较——我当然不是在责怪你沉溺其中，我自己也绝对会这样做。有时这只是本能——但它实际上并没有让我们改变生活或朝着我们想要的方行得更轻松。因此，佛罗里达大学 2022 年的一项研究发现，
frequently we compare ourselves on things like timelines, the fewer positive feelings we have about ourselves and the less we feel that we can act to change our life or be better, do better. So it becomes a bit of a trap. You feel shit in comparison to someone else that's going to make you feel like you have no capability or agency to make your life better. So you stay stuck. I think, again, what exacerbates this and makes it harder is when nobody is talking about it.
frequently we compare ourselves on things like timelines, the fewer positive feelings we have about ourselves and the less we feel that we can act to change our life or be better, do better. So it becomes a bit of a trap. You feel shit in comparison to someone else that's making you feel like you have no capability or agency to make your life better. So you stay stuck. I think, again, what exacerbates this and makes it harder is when nobody is talking about it.|||我们在时间线之类的事情上进行自我比较的频率越高，我们对自己的积极感受就越少，我们就越觉得自己无法采取行动去改变生活或变得更好、做得更好。所以这变成了一个陷阱。与别人相比，你会觉得自己像个渣滓，这让你觉得自己没有能力或自主权去让生活变得更好。于是你陷入困境，停滞不前。我认为，再次强调，加剧这种情况并使之变得更加困难的是，没有人谈论它。
When nobody is willing to say, yeah, I made a mistake. and I'm starting over. Or this didn't work out and I'm starting over. So just simply telling your story and being open about how your life is turning out and how it might not be turning out as planned, we feel like we are the only one who is experiencing this and we feel like we are admitting to some failure. That brings a lot of shame about not just what we are doing, but our inherent qualities, right? this is why it can be so painful because we think that admitting to our life plan not working out
When nobody is willing to say, yeah, I made a mistake. and I'm starting over. Or this didn't work out and I'm starting over. So just simply telling your story and being open about how your life is turning out and how it might not be turning out as planned, we feel like we are the only one who is experiencing this and we feel like we are admitting to some failure. That brings a lot of shame about not just what we are doing, but our inherent qualities, right? this is why it can be so painful because we think that admitting to our life plan not working out|||当没有人愿意说：“是的，我犯了错误。我要重新开始。”或者“这行不通，我要重新开始。”因此，仅仅是通过讲述你的故事，并坦诚地面对你的生活是如何发展的，以及它可能没有按照计划进行，我们会觉得自己是唯一一个经历这一切的人，我们会觉得自己是在承认某种失败。这不仅对我们正在做的事情，而且对我们内在的品质带来了很多羞耻感，对吧？这就是为什么这会如此痛苦，因为我们认为承认我们的人生计划没有奏效
shows that we are someone who wasn't good enough wasn't capable enough wasn't resilient enough didn't deserve some success when really that is not the case your brain logic in this instance is not working in your favor it's actually sabotaging our ego and sense of self further almost because it would prefer that we be the ones to tell ourselves that we're a failure than have someone else tell us. So if we go into this and we have no examples of anyone else experiencing what we're experiencing or normalizing it and then we feel like we have to tell people and admit to it,
shows that we are someone who wasn't good enough wasn't capable enough wasn't resilient enough didn't deserve some success when really that is not the case your brain logic in this instance is not working in your favor it's actually sabotaging our ego and sense of self further almost because it would prefer that we be the ones to tell ourselves that we're a failure than have someone else tell us. So if we go into this and we have no examples of anyone else experiencing what we're experiencing or normalizing it and then we feel like we have to tell people and admit to it,|||表明我们是一个不够优秀、不够有能力、不够有韧性、不配获得某种成功的人，而事实并非如此。在这种情况下，你大脑的逻辑对你不利，它实际上进一步破坏了我们的自我和自我意识，几乎是因为它宁愿是我们自己告诉自己我们是个失败者，也不愿让别人告诉我们。因此，如果我们进入这种状态，并且没有任何其他人经历过我们正在经历的事情或将其正常化的例子，然后我们觉得我们必须告诉别人并承认这一点，
our brain's going to convince us that we are much more horrible, terrible, much more of a failure than we actually are almost just a way to protect our ego by injuring it in the first place. So comparison, a fear of failure, that's definitely what makes starting over externally scary, but let's talk about some of the internal, more personal reasons that we do tend to struggle in these situations. The first big one is a fear of the unknown.
our brain's going to convince us that we are much more horrible, terrible, much more of a failure than we actually are almost just a way to protect our ego by injuring it in the first place. So comparison, a fear of failure, that's definitely what makes starting over externally scary, but let's talk about some of the internal, more personal reasons that we do tend to struggle in these situations. The first big one is a fear of the unknown.|||我们的大脑会说服我们，我们比实际情况要糟糕得多、可怕得多、失败得多，这几乎只是为了通过一开始就伤害我们的自我来保护我们的自我。所以比较、对失败的恐惧，这绝对是让外部重新开始变得可怕的原因，但让我们来谈谈我们在这些情况下往往会苦苦挣扎的一些内在的、更个人的原因。第一个大原因是恐惧未知。
Truly, any fear that you have comes down to this greater fear of the unknown. Because if you knew what was going to happen, if you knew that the snake wouldn't bite you, the plane wouldn't crash, that everything would turn out okay, you wouldn't be scared. You wouldn't be scared. So it's the uncertainty that matters. How many of us have wished someone would just be able to concretely say that for certain, everything will be all right.
Truly, any fear that you have comes down to this greater fear of the unknown. Because if you knew what was going to happen, if you knew that the snake wouldn't bite you, the plane wouldn't crash, that everything would turn out okay, you wouldn't be scared. You wouldn't be scared. So it's the uncertainty that matters. How many of us have wished someone would just be able to concretely say that for certain, everything will be all right.|||真的，你所有的恐惧都可以归结为对未知的巨大恐惧。因为如果你知道会发生什么，如果你知道蛇不会咬你，飞机不会坠毁，一切都会好起来的，你就不会害怕了。你不会害怕的。所以不确定性才是关键。我们中有多少人曾希望某人能够确切地说出一切都会好起来的。
Oh, and you know, by the way, in three months, that's when you're going to find the new job. And you're going to meet your soulmate in approximately 17 months and nine days. And in two weeks, you'll have one of those days where everything about this new life makes sense. we all hunger and crave that kind of validation that we are on the right path. Thing is, no one can tell us that. No one is going to be able to give you the answer and tell you when it's all going to fall into place. Therefore, we have to manage this very natural anxiety around the unknown by ourselves the best we can. The alternative is staying attached to what is comfortable, the stagnant career, the unhappy relationship, the unfulfilling friendship,
Oh, and you know, by the way, in three months, that's when you're going to find the new job. And you're going to meet your soulmate in approximately 17 months and nine days. And in two weeks, you'll have one of those days where everything about this new life makes sense. we all hunger and crave that kind of validation that we are on the right path. Thing is, no one can tell us that. No one is going to be able to give you the answer and tell you when it's all going to fall into place. Therefore, we have to manage this very natural anxiety around the unknown by ourselves the best we can. The alternative is staying attached to what is comfortable, the stagnant career, the unhappy relationship, the unfulfilling friendship,|||哦，你知道，顺便说一句，在三个月内，那就是你找到新工作的时候。你将在大约 17 个月零 9 天后遇到你的灵魂伴侣。两周后，你将迎来这样一天，新生活的一切都变得有意义。我们都渴望并渴求这种证明我们走在正确道路上的确认。问题是，没有人能告诉我们这一点。没有人能给你答案并告诉你这一切什么时候会尘埃落定。因此，我们必须尽我们所能自己管理这种围绕未知的非常自然的焦虑。另一种选择是依恋舒适的事物，停滞不前的职业，不幸的关系，毫无成就感的友谊，
the city, the place that doesn't give you any joy, you could always stay there. You could always remain in this nice, comfortable, safe bubble because you are too scared of what might happen. I just don't think that is a good alternative. And what are you going to be more glad that you did in a year? In five years, in ten years, are you going to be glad that you stayed safe and you stayed locked away? Or are you going to be glad that you looked at your life, you said, I'm not. not happy here and you change things. I do also want to offer you a different way of framing this, which is that life would be utterly and completely boring if you knew how it was all going to turn out.
这座城市，这个根本带给你任何快乐的地方，你总是可以待在这里。你总是可以留在这个美好、舒适、安全的泡沫里，因为你太害怕可能会发生的事情了。我只是觉得这不是一个好的选择。一年后，五年后，十年后，你会为自己做了什么而感到更加高兴？在五年、十年后，你会为自己保持安全并把自己锁起来而感到高兴吗？还是你会为自己审视了生活，然后说，我在这里并不快乐，并做出了改变而感到高兴？我也想为你提供另一种看待这个问题的方式，那就是如果生活完全如你所料，那将是无比无聊的。
It would honestly be such a drag to know how everything was going to unfold down to the minute details, how everything was going to turn out. Honestly, it would seem very pointless to be living this life with no anticipation and no surprises. So even if there is not a lot of joy in not knowing and not a lot of joy in the chaos, I do think that the alternative would be even more horrendous. So let's talk about the final reason why I think starting over in our 20s is so hard. And that is because of the loss of identity that we experience when we transition away from our career choices or our relationship or the places of comfort. A lot of people think that identity formation takes place in our childhood, and in many ways that is true, but it also really gets tested and solidified in our
老实说，如果每件事会如何发展都精确到分钟的细节，一切会如何结果都一清二楚，那真的会让人觉得索然无味。老实说，如果生活没有期待、没有惊喜，这样活着会显得毫无意义。所以，即使未知之中没有太多的快乐，混乱之中也没有太多的快乐，但我确实认为另一种选择会更加可怕。那么我们来谈谈最后一个原因，为什么我认为二十多岁时重新开始会如此艰难。那就是因为当我们远离职业选择、关系或舒适的地方时，我们经历的身份认同感的丧失。很多人认为身份认同感是在童年时期形成的，在很多方面这确实如此，但它同样在我们的
20s. Our identity, I'd like to think about it as being made up of many buckets, from values to culture, to relationships, career, hobbies, appearance, beliefs. We tend to piece our identity together from things that surround us and attach significance to positions and roles like our job title, like who we're dating, like where we live, our environment. Now, when those things naturally fall away, when we are forced to start over when some spanner is thrown into the wheel, we feel very unmoored from the pillars of who we are. you're kind of just left with a few remnants of your identity when material or I guess outside things fall away. So let me use the example of a long-term relationship.
二十多岁时真正受到考验并得以巩固。我喜欢把我们的身份认同想象成由许多部分组成，从价值观到文化、到人际关系、职业、爱好、外表、信仰。我们往往把周围的事物拼凑成我们的身份认同，并将重要性赋予职位和角色，比如我们的职称，我们和谁约会，我们住在哪里，我们的环境。现在，当这些东西自然而然地消逝，当我们被迫重新开始，当生活中出现一些意外时，我们会觉得自己失去了自我基石的依托。当物质或者说外界的事物消逝时，你某种程度上只剩下了一点身份认同的残余。所以让我用长期恋爱关系来举例。
When a long-term relationship ends, often people will struggle rebuilding a full and complete sense of self because they've really tied themselves up in this other person. So they may have neglected the things that really do make them unique, like their interests or their beliefs. or their values and so you really have to work your way back to that place of deep self-knowledge because you can no longer rely on this relationship or this other person to define you and that is going to be emotionally painful and stressful and scary if you didn't think you were going to be here I've seen this happen in so many friends relationships and to be completely honest with you I'm sure that if me and my boyfriend or my partner broke up right now
当一段长期的恋爱关系结束时，人们往往很难重建一个完整而全面的自我意识，因为他们真的把自己和另一个人紧紧绑在了一起。所以他们可能忽视了那些真正让他们变得独特的事物，比如他们的兴趣、信仰或价值观。所以你必须真正努力回到那个深刻的自我认知的地方，因为你不能再依靠这段关系或另一个人来定义你，如果你没想到自己会落得如此境地，那将会是情感上的痛苦、压力和恐惧。我看到许多朋友的关系中都发生过这种情况，说实话，我敢肯定，如果我和我的男友或伴侣现在分手了
it would be likely that I would fall into this same spiral because naturally when you care about someone when you're imagining a future with them, you sort of neglect the parts of you that would allow you to be fully independent and that would allow your identity to be fully formed on your own. I don't think that's a bad thing at all. I think that's a sign of healthy, reliance and dependency.
我很可能会陷入同样的旋涡，因为很自然地，当你关心一个人，当你想象着和他们的未来时，你某种程度上会忽略那些能让你完全独立的自我部分，以及能让你的身份完全靠自己塑造的部分。我一点也不认为这是一件坏事。我认为这是健康信赖和依赖的标志。
It is just an adjustment. Okay, so far we have really zoned in on explaining the hard parts of starting over and why our feelings about it to emerge, I think it is time that we shift to a more future-oriented, positive approach, and really examine how we can use psychology and what we know about ourselves as humans to use these unfortunate fresh starts to our advantage. So when we come back, I'm going to talk advice, I'm going to talk leveraging transitional periods,
这只是一种调整。好了，到目前为止，我们已经着重解释了重新开始的艰难部分以及为什么我们的这些感受会涌现，我认为是时候转向一种更具未来导向、积极的方法了，并真正研究我们如何利用心理学以及我们对自己作为人类的了解，将这些不幸的全新开始转化为我们的优势。所以当我们回来时，我将谈谈建议，我将谈谈如何利用过渡期，
and why the best time to start over is actually right now. We'll be back right after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers,
以及为什么重新开始的最佳时机其实就是现在。我们在这个短暂的广告之后马上回来。2%。这是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析精神韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员、
and other health and fitness experts. and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-P-Sent on the I-E-E-R-E-E-R-E-R-E-E-R-E-E-R-E-E-R-E. I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，带大家看透充斥着健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾以为种子油天生就会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些磨难，你将会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的姿态涅槃重生。收听“2%”。这就是 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的 T-W-O-P-P-E-N-T。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在 VMA 上双击小金姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在“回顾过去”播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段日期的。
including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so... Thank you for finishing that sentence.
其中包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔畅谈 80 年代可卡因的节目。坦白说，84 年对我很重要，不仅因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊一聊可卡因，只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集，所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的主线了。我们现在还要讨论艾滋病，所以……谢谢你把那句话说完。
Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years. from black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
是的，我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听“回顾过去”。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
欢迎来到我的新播客《迎难而上》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们盯着记分牌，生活变成了输赢史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世上做一个好人很重要，还是你做个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
绝对是的。这是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，我们将在我的新播客《迎难而上》中就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索《迎难而上》并立即收听。2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于父子关系丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Lens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
这开启了一场历时多年的法庭之战来证明真相。兰斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
Greg Alesspian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
格雷格·阿莱斯皮安，迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So I want to tell you why the best time for you to start over is right now, as promised. If you are going to choose a moment to reinvent yourself and to leave environments, in places that don't serve you in your 20s, it would be right now. You will never be as young with as much future time in front of you as you have in this moment. You can spend hours, weeks, months ruminating on what could have happened. You can reflect and think if I'd just done this, if I've just done that, but these hypotheticals are not in the realm of your control. So, unfortunate as it is, I think it is a loss caused to.
在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。所以我想如约告诉你为什么重新开始的最佳时机就是现在。如果你要在二十多岁时选择一个时刻来重塑自我，离开那些不再适合你的环境和地方，那就是现在。你永远不会像此时此刻这样年轻，眼前有着如此多的未来时间。你可以花几个小时、几周、几个月去反刍那些本可能发生的事情。你可以反思，心想如果我当时这么做了，如果我当时那么做了，但这些假设并不在你的掌控范围内。所以，尽管很不幸，我认为这是一种毫无意义的
reflect on the past with longing because it can't change anything but luckily you have been given the gift of a new beginning and your 20s are a great time to start over again and again and again because of just how flexible and adaptable we are and our lives are and our brains are it is such a unique time for reinvention although you know our brains continue to change and develop over our lifetime. Our 20s are actually the second most formative period for brain development in our life. And that works in your favor. It's easier for you to rewire certain pathways, to form new attachments, to learn new skills, to be resilient, because we are so adaptable and you can create a whole new neurological system based on this new life you're creating. I think we all know the saying you can't
带着渴望去反思过去，因为它无法改变任何事情，但幸运的是，你被赋予了重新开始的礼物，而你的二十多岁是反复重新开始的好时机，因为我们、我们的生活以及我们的大脑是如此灵活和适应力强，这是一个极其独特的重塑时期。尽管你知道我们的大脑在整个人生中都在不断改变和发展。我们的二十多岁实际上是我们一生中大脑发育的第二个最具形成性的时期。这对外有利。你更容易重新连结某些神经通路，形成新的依恋，学习新技能，变得富有韧性，因为我们适应力极强，你可以根据你正在创造的新生活建立一个全新的神经系统。我想我们都知道这句俗语：你无法
teach an old dog new tricks. And in some ways that's true. the old you get, the harder it is to give yourself the gift of a fresh start. I also want to remind you, you are still incredibly young. Even if you are listening to this and you're not in your 20s, you're in your early 30s or your early 40s, my gosh, there are people in their 60s, 70s, 80s, who would look at your life and say, to have the time you have, if only I had changed at your age, if only I had let myself. I think I've said this quote before actually,
教老狗新把戏。在某种程度上确实如此。你越老，给自己送上一份全新开始的礼物就越难。我也想提醒你，你依然年轻得不可思议。即使你听着这个节目，你已经不在二十多岁了，而是在三十岁出头或四十岁出头，天哪，有六十岁、七十岁、八十岁的人看着你的生活会说，要是有你这样的时间多好，如果我当年在你这个年纪改变了就好了，如果我当时允许自己……我想我以前其实说过这句名言，
but it's one that really sticks with me. It's not necessarily a quote, but it's a video of Rees Witherspoon, you know, from Legally Blonde. And she is being interviewed by someone who was 29. And the girl tells her how old she is and she says, how do you go about getting into film when you're a bit older? And Reese asks her, how old are you? She goes, I'm 29.
但它是一句真正铭刻在我心中的话。它不一定是一句名言，而是一段瑞茜·威瑟斯彭的视频，你知道的，就是《律政俏佳人》里的那个。她正在接受一个 29 岁的人的采访。那个女孩告诉了她自己的年龄，然后她问，当你年龄稍大一点时，你是如何进入电影行业的？瑞茜问她，你多大了？她回答说，我 29 岁。
She goes, oh my goodness. you're just a baby. If you could see yourself from my perspective, you are so young and you have so much time. And that gave me so much reassurance that really all these experienced wonderful people who a lot of us admire and respect would look at where we're at right now
她接着说，哦天哪。你简直是个婴儿。如果你能从我的角度看自己，你太年轻了，而且你有那么多时间。这给了我极大的安慰，真的，许多我们许多人钦佩和尊敬的有经验的优秀人士，看着我们现在的处境
and say, this is just the beginning. If I was going to start over, I'd be doing it right now. It's also worth noting that I definitely believe that life comes in cycles. So you just have to be prepared and open-minded. You may be starting over now and then you may be starting over again at 40, at 65. But at least you'll have some experience on how to navigate this transition and you have practice because change is really the only thing that is promised and if you hide away from it,
会说，这仅仅是个开始。如果我要重新开始，我现在就会去做。同样值得一提的是，我坚信生命是呈周期性循环的。所以你只需要做好准备并保持开放的心态。你现在可能在重新开始，然后你在 40 岁、65 岁时可能又会重新开始。但至少你将拥有如何驾驭这种过渡的一些经验，并且你拥有练习，因为变化确实是唯一得到保证的事情，如果你对它避之不及，
eventually it will grab you and it would be better to know how to handle that. So that is some of my more philosophical advice ramblings around why this isn't the disaster that maybe you think it is. although you're allowed to feel that way. If you're still in the morning grieving period for what once was, that's okay. But I want to teach you how you can try and reframe this chapter of your life, as hard and confusing as it may have been, and move forward. And I have some tips for you on that as well. Start small.
它最终会抓住你，而懂得如何应对它会更好。这些是我关于为什么这不是你想象中的那场灾难的一些更具哲学性的建议和闲谈，尽管你有权利去那样感受。如果你仍然处于对曾经逝去事物的哀悼期，那也没关系。但我想教你如何试着重新构建你人生的这一篇章，无论它曾多么艰难和令人困惑，并继续前行。关于这一点，我也有些小建议。从小事做起。
If you have experienced a setback or a failure and you're trying to rebuild, start small. Start small by talking to people in industries that you think you may enjoy. Start small by going on a really low-key date, by journaling what you could possibly, what kind of life you could possibly fall in love with. If you're trying to restart after a big friendship breakup or a loss, give yourself time to grieve and then slowly get back out there. Take baby steps so that every single step of the way you are being intentional. I think let's use the metaphor of starting with a blank canvas when you're painting, right? I don't know many of us who would rush to fill every single square inch of that canvas in minutes.
如果你经历了挫折或失败，并且正试图重建，从小事做起。从小事做起，与你认为自己可能会喜欢的行业的业内人士交谈。从小事做起，去约一次非常轻松的会，写日记记录你可能会、可能会爱上什么样的生活。如果你在经历了一次重大的友谊破裂或失去后试图重新开始，给自己时间去哀悼，然后慢慢重新融入社交。采取小步前进的方式，这样你在每一步中都是有意识的。我想让我们用作画时从一张空白画布开始的比喻，对吧？我认识的人中，没几个会急着在几分钟内填满那张画布的每一平方英寸。
Because inherent in that is that we see an opportunity to create something big and vibrant, You know, we've been given this huge canvas, this huge place to put all our feelings. So we want to be intentional with what we're putting on there. And the same goes for rebuilding the area of your life where you may have felt like you had to start over. I would say focus on one area that you really want to find either stability, abundance, growth, whatever it is, and make a bit of a master plan. I have really fallen in love with the idea of a master plan recently. And basically it's like a map of the next. six months to a year that holds multiple desires or dreams or goals for you and it feels less specific
因为其中隐含着我们看到了创造宏大而充满活力之物的机会，你知道的，我们得到了这幅巨大的画布，这片巨大的地方来倾注我们所有的情感。所以我们要对放在上面的东西保持专注。重建生活中你可能觉得不得不重新开始的领域也是如此。我会说，专注于你真正想要找到稳定、丰盛、成长或其他什么的某一领域，并制定一个宏伟计划。我最近真的爱上了宏伟计划这个概念。基本上它就像未来六个月到一年的地图，包含了你多重愿望、梦想或目标，它感觉没有
than a strict singular goal that you're working towards it lets you focus on how you want to make progress in everything in your life how you want to feel my master plan i really like to have you know how am i going to be feeling in two weeks in a month in three months in six months what do i have to change now to get me there. If it is that you want to feel more secure in your purpose and what you actually want to do in your life, maybe the first three months are going to be an explorative chapter for you where you're just trying out different hats, where you are networking, where you are investigating what could really light your fire. That is great. That is still part of the master plan that is still progress forward, I really want to wipe away, get rid of this
你正在努力实现的严格的单一目标那么具体，它让你专注于你希望如何在生活中各方面取得进展，你希望如何感受。我的宏伟计划，我真的很喜欢明确：我在两周后、一个月后、三个月后、六个月后会有什么感觉？我现在必须改变什么才能到达那里。如果你的愿望是在你的目标以及你真正想在生活中做的事情上感到更有安全感，也许头三个月对你来说将是一个探索性的篇章，在这个阶段你只是在尝试不同的角色，在进行社交网络建设，在探索到底是什么能点燃你的激情。那太棒了。那仍然是宏伟计划的一部分，仍然是向前的进展。我真的很想抹去、摆脱这种
idea that when you start over, you have to know exactly what you need and what you want from the get-go. This is a time where you can really shake things up. You can change your priorities. You can reinvent yourself. So when you're putting together a master plan, maybe it's like a visual timeline of where you want to be in six months with pictures, with words, with different themes. Make sure that you leave some space also just to explore. Also embrace a growth versus fixed mindset in this moment. A growth mindset, this was first described by the psychologist Carol Dweck and it's this real belief that our abilities, our intelligence, our talent can be developed over time through effort, through learning, through perseverance.
想法，即当你重新开始时，你必须从一开始就知道你需要什么以及你想要什么。这是一个你可以真正大洗牌的时刻。你可以改变你的优先事项。你可以重塑自我。所以在制定宏伟计划时，也许它就像一张视觉时间线，用图片、文字、不同的主题展示你希望在六个月后身处何地。确保你同时也留出一些空间去探索。在这个时刻还要拥抱成长心态与固定心态。成长心态，这最初是由心理学家卡罗尔·德韦克提出的，这是一种真正的信念，即我们的能力、我们的智力、我们的天赋可以通过努力、学习、坚持不懈随时间得到发展。
And this perspective really fosters resilience and it makes you curious. It makes empty space promising rather than restrictive because you know that you can fill it with things that you love and that you are capable of creating the life that you want because you are in control. You have agency. In contrast, a fixed mindset really is this belief that the parts about you that you want change, they're unchangeable. You can't grow. You can't change. You're not capable. And that leads to a real fear of failure and avoidance of risk and a tendency to just give up and revert to what is comfortable
这种视角确实能培养韧性，并使你保持好奇心。它让空白的空间充满希望，而不是限制重重，因为你知道你可以用你喜欢的事物去填补它，并且你有能力创造你想要的生活，因为你掌握着主动权。你有自主权。相比之下，固定心态其实是一种信念，即你想改变的那些关于你自身的特质是无法改变的。你无法成长。你无法改变。你没有能力。这会导致对失败的真正恐惧、对风险的规避，以及在面对未知时倾向于放弃并退回到舒适区的倾向
when we are faced with the unknown. Psychologically, a growth mindset is what we are after because it makes you better at responding to fear. It means that you're better at problem solving. it means that you are willing to learn. So when you are starting over in your 20s, what I want you to do and the kind of growth mindset that I want you to adopt is that you're going to view setbacks as opportunities for growth. You are going to approach new challenges with curiosity.
从心理学角度来看，成长心态正是我们所追求的，因为它能让你更好地应对恐惧。这意味着你更擅长解决问题，意味着你愿意学习。因此，当你在二十多岁重新开始时，我希望你做的事情以及我希望你采用的成长心态是，你要将挫折视为成长的机会。你要带着好奇心去迎接新的挑战。
You're going to think, not what do I have to be fearful of here, but what can I learn even within the fear? And I want you to understand that this is a process and that you are actually writing a very interesting story. You are not writing a story just with a beginning, a middle, and an end. You are writing a story with a plot. And I think that that is a much better way to think about it
你会想，在这里我不是要害怕什么，而是在恐惧中我能学到什么？我希望你明白这是一个过程，你实际上是在写一个非常有趣的故事。你写的可不仅仅是一个有开头、有中间、有结尾的故事。你写的是一个有情节的故事。我认为这是一个好得多的思考方式，
and a much better attitude to bring to things. Like, I'm not looking for the easiest route. I'm looking for the route with the most experience and abundance and fucking fun, you know, and just cool stories and cool things that I get to show and tell people about when I'm older. Another thing I would really say to do if you've just gone through a breakup, if you've just quit a job that was toxic, if you're moving somewhere new soon, do something that represents this new era physically, something that feels psychologically symbolic. So a new tattoo, a new haircut, a wardrobe purge, something or other that is going to make you feel like every single part of you is in this new version of you and is in this new beginning with you. that old version of you, we respect them, we love them, they've taught us so much, it's their time to rest.
也是带入事物的更好态度。比如，我不是在寻找最简单的路线。我在寻找一条拥有最丰富的经历、最充沛的丰盛感以及他妈的无限乐趣的路线，你知道的，还有当我年老时可以向人们展示和讲述的那些酷炫的故事和酷炫的事情。另一件我真的建议你去做的事情是，如果你刚刚经历了一场分手，如果你刚刚辞掉了一份有毒的工作，如果你很快就要搬到一个新地方，做一些在物理上代表这个新时代的事情，一些在心理上感觉具有象征意义的事情。比如一个新的纹身、一个新发型、一次衣橱大扫除，或者别的什么东西，能让你觉得你身上的每一部分都进入了这个新版本的你，并与你一同迎来了这个崭新的开始。那个旧版本的我们，我们尊重他们，我们爱他们，他们教给我们太多，是时候让他们休息了。
Like, it's their time, it's time to say goodbye to them. This new chapter is coming with a fresh new look. It's coming with a new attitude and we're going to represent that physically. If comparison is also the thing that you are struggling with the most in this moment, and I totally understand that it would be, right? As I said, it's something that's built into our DNA as humans. I want you to make sure that any comparison statements you're making are not full sentences. So let me explain this a little bit further.
就像，这是他们的时刻，是时候跟他们说再见了。这个新篇章将伴随着崭新的面貌到来。它将伴随着全新的态度，我们将通过实际行动来体现这一点。如果比较也是你此刻最挣扎的事情，我完全理解为什么会这样，对吧？正如我所说，这是我们人类DNA中内置的东西。我希望确保你所做的任何比较陈述都不是完整的句子。所以让我进一步解释这一点。
When we have a tendency to compare, we might look at someone's life and go, oh my gosh, she has everything. Her life is so perfect. I don't have that. But I want you to then take that sentence and expand it. I don't have that, but that doesn't mean I never will. her career looks so successful and one day mine will look like that as well. I am so jealous of her, whatever it is, her relationship because mine failed. But that doesn't mean that every future relationship of mine is going to fail.
当我们有比较的倾向时，我们可能会看着别人的生活说，哦天哪，她拥有一切。她的生活太完美了。我没有那个。但我希望你随后能把那个句子扩展开来。我没有那个，但这并不意味着我永远不会有；她的职业看起来如此成功，总有一天我的也会看起来那样；我很嫉妒她，无论是什么，她的关系，因为我的失败了。但这并不意味着我的每一段未来关系都会失败。
Their success does not inherently mean my failure. Not everything has to be a competition. sometimes the lives of people that we admire most shows up through jealousy and instead of treating them as this person who we need to be threatened by we can be inspired by them and say huh like doesn't this just show me that this is capable that i could do this i'm sure they've experienced setbacks as well and yet here they are finally surround yourself or reflect on examples of people who have started over and been successful in their 20s. And let me say, there's not many of them
他们的成功并不本质上意味着我的失败。并非一切都必须是一场竞争。有时我们最钦佩的人的生活是通过嫉妒显现出来的，而我们不用把他们当成我们需要感到受到威胁的对象，我们可以从他们身上得到启发，心想，哈，难道这不正好向我展示了这是完全可能的，我也可以做到吗？我敢肯定他们也经历过挫折，然而他们还是走到了今天。环顾四周或回想那些在二十多岁时重新开始并取得成功的人的例子。而且我要说，这样的人并不多
because most people actually end up starting over later in their 40s, in their 50s. Like your 20s is still your genesis. It's still your origin story. This is still the first timeline you were living. I love to give the example, actually, of my mom. My mom is one of those people who, I love hearing the story of how when she was in her 20s,
因为大多数人实际上最终是在稍后的 40 岁、50 岁时才重新开始。就像你的二十多岁依然是你的创世纪。依然是你的起源故事。这仍然是你所经历的第一条时间线。其实，我很喜欢举我妈妈的例子。我妈妈就是那种人，我喜欢听这样一个故事：当她在二十多岁时，
she was kicked out of her university faculty for such poor grades. She did absolutely terribly. And, you know, it looks like she wasn't going to get a degree. But she went and she did other things. She, quote, unquote, found herself and she came back when she was older and wiser. And she gave it another go. And a lot of people were like, why are you doing that?
她因为成绩太差而被大学专业开除了。她做得绝对糟糕透顶。而且，你知道的，看起来她拿不到学位了。但她去了，做了别的事情。她，“引用”寻找了自我，等她年纪更大、更成熟时她回来了。她又尝试了一次。很多人都在问，你为什么这么做？
You know, you already failed once. Why are you trying this economics thing, this psychology thing for a second time? She ended up being the, like, valedictorian ducks of her class at university. and she went on to get this incredible grad job. Now she is literally a CEO. And I love to look at that story and say, you know, she was an immigrant and she, I don't know, sorry, I'm getting so inspired by my mom's story. But I love to look at that story and go, wow, this is someone who I admire who has made
你知道的，你已经失败过一次了。为什么还要第二次尝试经济学、心理学这些东西？她最后成了大学里的毕业典礼演讲代表、班级第一名。并且她接着找到了一份令人难以置信的优厚工作。现在她简直是个首席执行官。我喜欢看那个故事并心想，你知道的，她曾是一个移民，她，我不知道，抱听着，我被我妈妈的故事深深鼓舞了。但我喜欢看着那个故事并心想，哇，这是一个我钦佩的人，她让
my life possible and she did not have the easiest ride of things. And there were so many times where I'm sure she was looking at other people thinking, I'm never going to be at their level, and yet she still found great success. Martha Stewart, oh my God, you have to watch the Martha Stewart documentary if you haven't, but she didn't write her first cookbook until she was 41. And that's what she's known for now. Steve Carell, we love Steve Carell, Michael in the office. You know, he didn't have his big break until he was in his 40s.
我的生活成为可能，而她的人生道路并非一帆风顺。有那么多次，我确信她看着别人心里在想，我永远也达不到他们的水平，然而她依然取得了巨大的成功。玛莎·斯图尔特，哦天哪，如果你还没看过玛莎·斯图尔特的纪录片，你一定要看，但她直到 41 岁才写了第一本食谱。而这正是她现在广为人知的原因。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，我们爱史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，《办公室》里的迈克尔。你知道的，他直到 40 多岁才迎来事业的大爆发。
Same with Harrison Ford. Most people do not find their greatest successes until later in life. and they sure don't find themselves until later as well. So you have time. I promise you you have so much time. You are so young. And the power of your 20s is that all of the possibility lays ahead of you. There is so much room for reinvention and to be able to start over.
哈里森·福特也是如此。大多数人在晚年才迎来最伟大的成功，而且他们也确实是在后来才真正认识了自己。所以你有时间。我向你保证，你有那么多的时间。你太年轻了。二十多岁的力量在于，所有的可能性都铺陈在你眼前。有如此巨大的空间供你重塑自我并重新开始。
Also, there's less consequences. You know, you don't have kids yet. You may not have a mortgage. You don't have other huge things to take care of that become more pressing. The old you get. you have more time in front of you than you have behind you. So I really want you to remember that when you are stressed or anxious about feeling like you failed the first time or you didn't get it right.
此外，后果更少。你知道的，你还没有孩子。你可能还没有房贷。你没有其他随着年龄增长而变得更加紧迫的巨大事情要照顾。你面前的时间比你身后的时间还要多。所以我真的希望当你因为觉得自己第一次失败了或者没有做对而感到压力或焦虑时，你能记住这一点。
Because that, again, is part of the interesting story you are writing. And I think that is much more important than being able to say, yeah, I got it all right and did everything perfectly the first time and I never made mistakes. Also means you never learned anything. So I hope this episode has provided you with some clarity. maybe just some peace, just a sense of like, okay, it's all going to be okay. That is really all I hope for with any of these podcast episodes is just that you can, you know, hear the words and the voice of someone else in their 20s and go, okay, it's not just me. Because it definitely isn't.
因为这同样构成了你正在书写的有趣故事的一部分。我认为这比能够说“是的，我第一次就全做对了，把每件事都做得完美无缺，而且我从不犯错”要重要得多。这也意味着你从没学到过任何东西。所以我希望这一集能为你提供一些清晰的思路，或者只是一些平静，一种“好吧，一切都会好起来的”的感觉。这其实就是我对任何一集播客的全部期盼，那就是你能听到另一个二十多岁的人的话语和声音，然后心想，好吧，不只是我一个人这样。因为绝不仅仅只有我。
Make sure that if you enjoyed this episode, you share it with a friend. You share it on your Instagram story anywhere. And if you do actually tag me, I love seeing the different parts of the world where people. are listening. It's honestly one of my favorite parts of the day is being like, oh my gosh, someone in Kenya, someone in Brussels, someone in Bristol. So please feel free to share it over there. Make sure you are following along on Apple, Podcasts or Spotify and that you have left a five-star review if you enjoyed this episode. Also drop a comment below if you have further thoughts about reinvention and starting over in your 20s. I love to keep the conversation going there.
如果你喜欢这一集，请确保把它分享给朋友。把它分享到你的 Instagram 快拍或任何地方。如果你真的艾特了我，我喜欢看到人们在世界各地收听的那些不同地方。老实说，这是我一天中最喜欢的时刻之一，那就是看到：哦天哪，肯尼亚有人，布鲁塞尔有人，布里斯托尔有人。所以请随时在那里分享。确保你在 Apple Podcasts 或 Spotify 上关注了我们，如果你喜欢这一集，请留下五星好评。如果你对在二十多岁重塑自我和重新开始有更多想法，也请在下方留言。我喜欢在那里继续我们的对话。
And I just love to hear from you guys. So until next time, stay safe. safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself, especially if you are in these circumstances. And we will talk very, very soon. Two percent. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthy, Your person. Listen to 2%.
我也很喜欢听你们的分享。所以直到下次，保重。注意安全，要善良，对自己温柔一点，尤其是当你身处这些环境时。我们很快就会再次聊起。百分之二。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析精神韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些磨难，你将会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的姿态涅槃重生。收听“2%”。
That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
这就是 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的 TWO% 。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定采取自己的方式。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girl friends. friends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝，在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
On The Look Back at It Podcasts. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
在“回顾过去”播客中。从 1979 年开始，这对我是个大时刻。84 年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段日期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的朋友以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important. Year for Black people. Listen to look back at it on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
84 年是个疯狂的年份。那是个疯狂的年份。我认为没有比这更重要的。对黑人而言的年份了。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听“回顾过去”。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听的是由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯带来的《迎难而上》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行着坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。
How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就非得这么做。在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《迎难而上》。这是一档 iHeart 播客。保证是由真人制作。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。